how's your wrist my welcome to summer
Alcala is raped it's gonna be fun
you're gonna play a lot of them today
cuz I I don't know what else to play
that rhymed holy [ __ ]
I have rap career future I could be the
next one direction they don't rap [ __ ]
the first one is called ocean rift at
the notion in the rift that was a joke I
think somewhere and we are inside let
hold on hold your horses have a hostage
whoa whoa this is actually cool whoa
don't you dare attack me every time I I
forget how cool is [ __ ] oculus rift
[ __ ] is what the hell are you ain't
nobody attacking me okay they said this
was relaxing how is it relaxing is that
a seat whale it's a whale oh man you
sexy hey oh my god it's like fish AI oh
my god it's better than call of duty or
what I thought what the [ __ ] why is that
shark going I don't trust ya oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] this is Jenna oh [ __ ] scary man
I don't want to go down there how do I
get em up I can't jump
what the hell this is actually [ __ ]
scared okay we're going deeper
yes it's getting dark I don't know it's
not a gay sir or volcano is that a
volcano the hell this is not relaxing
don't appreciate this
this [ __ ] sea tentacles I do not like
it the [ __ ] am I supposed to go anyway
I hate I hate touching tentacles I don't
think anyone likes it unless you're a
hentai girl they seem to like it I don't
know why I don't know why I wonder why I
wonder how just the day you told me
about the touching man can I go inside
the tentacle spirit viola well that was
welcome G oculus rift
she's [ __ ] [ __ ] who made this
relaxing my ass my ass this actually is
the most comfortable part of my body
right now the next one is called bungy
it's a bungle bungle bungle jump is it
bungee or Bunge I know what it is
no one cares oh this looks bad this is
very oh [ __ ] my eye fell out 19 real
life don't worry see there we go alright
well this looks legit apparently I'm a
small less it's worse that's good
this is making me a little motion sick
it's not an octopus down there I ain't
jumping if they cannot walk to [ __ ] I
guess I Yolo is in order
I'll be too obvious how about tomato
salad
this makes me want to throw up
alright the next one is oculus dog
Doug's ISA dog is a dog Elsa
oh hey girl how you doing what the [ __ ]
is he doing
is there a foot - I see
your foot foot smells a bit have a nice
day
ah yeah ah ah it worked
I can still see your cat's eyes I won't
look at that sorry
Joe what did I do this is a dress okay
what the [ __ ] who make this [ __ ] me come
I thought you loved me why don't you
love me back please
I don't love your foot please please I
don't like I'm not a defeat these foot
two feet one for 20 feet yes another two
feet and I'm just appears okay stop that
it really I'd rate that one probably a
12 foot side of 10 pretty good the next
one is called colourful melody whoa
thank God for virtual reality as my
dreams coming true right am i naked -
come on naked whatever the next one is
called wheels out to see his little
girls succeeding at the things she loves
did you see this place today oh shut up
yes thank you very much
what
what the [ __ ]
Matisse - yes well cabe Russ we're okay
isn't there supposed to be people in
here now understand
hello hello how you doing Lefty
you okay how about you mr. Wright all
right that's cool all right I guess I'm
dying huh
maybe because no one [ __ ] works at
this hospital maybe that's why God what
[ __ ] those are still there save your
life
whoa oh yeah I can jump only [ __ ]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] okay I'm not playing
sorry I'm sorry I can't deal with that
voice acting okay we're gonna try give
you teen simulator I'm gonna have to
change this set up a little Bay as a
wise man once said he didn't say Yolo
he said don't [ __ ] say Yolo oh no hi
there handsome
oh no okay
but shut da yeah I'm innocent I swear I
live there went on she hit on me
she touched my but I didn't touch her
let that be clear you sons of [ __ ]
hi how am I supposed to know making out
with ducks is illegal
I'm Anna decided you're all a bunch of
goddamn rain sets you know what I don't
even give a [ __ ] right bring it on I'm
tracking look at me still Louie I don't
need a buddy bunch of duck races don't
worry I got don't worry I'm fine
what I'm fine all right that was about
all the time I had to have fun with the
oculars today hope we brothers enjoyed
watching in the lack of fit then it
helps me out and it makes yourself feel
better try it out you never know this is
great already I'll see you the next 1000
breast love you butter is so beautiful
such power are the insights look so nice